hello and welcome to a new video
here on code tech tutorials my name is
matt i'm going to show you some stuff
about
pointers and memory management with c
plus plus
and hopefully uh this helps you
understand some of this stuff because it
can be a bit confusing so in c plus plus
you have
pointers and there there's a whole
scope of things you could do with them
that is sometimes way more efficient
than passing around
actual objects and working with actual
objects because what a pointer is is
just a small bit of memory that says
here is the start of this object in
memory so it's just a little
tiny piece of information rather than
the entire object
so let's walk through this first example
to get started and then we'll get into
some more advanced topics
so i assume you already have some
general basic knowledge about how to
declare a pointer
and that sort of stuff but i'll i'll
kind of walk through it anyway
so here we have just a main that will
run
from top to bottom when we hit the play
button and
all this is here is a pointer
to a float called stuff now by itself
if you don't initialize it this is just
a pointer
to a chunk of memory but we don't know
what's in the memory until
we run this new operation on it and say
it equals a new float this now
assigns it and gives it its default
value with its default constructor
so the default constructor for a float
should be zero so once we do this whole
new float thing
we will get uh that stuff equals zero so
we should see that
and to cancel out this so if you do just
a standard console out
without a star in front of it what you
will get
is the pointer so you'll see a memory
address
so this right here would show the memory
address of stuff
but if we put a star in front of it we
will de-reference it
and look at the data that it's pointing
at so this one here should actually show
the value of zero
and then here we assign whatever it is
pointing at is we're dereferencing it
to say hey the data now equals 10. if we
didn't put this here
we would be saying the pointer equals
10f which makes no sense and it would
cause
problems hopefully your static analysis
would find that
but it would definitely definitely cause
some issues so now
we should see with this c out that the
value is now 10.
and what happens if we just delete this
float
so you call delete on a pointer it
deletes all the data
leaves the pointer just essentially
dangling and doing nothing
so you usually want to assign it to null
pointer but in general that's how you
get rid of it
and now to completely get rid of this
you would have to just let it go out of
scope
so before your pointer goes out of scope
typically
unless something else starts managing
the memory you want to delete the data
i know that sounds confusing but
basically if we're doing a thing like
like this and like this
so it's in a new scope once we get to
this section of our program just ignore
all this for a second
i'll comment it out so once we get to
this section of the program
our pointer would go out of scope but
this data
that it created with this new would
still just be sitting there in memory
and nothing would be pointing to it we'd
have no way to access it even though
it'd be sitting there in memory and
that's how you get memory leaks
so that's the whole point of the whole
delete thing
so before you leave this if you don't
need that data anymore
you would go just like that
and then shabam you're no longer just
sitting with memory
uh allocated with nothing pointed to it
no way to access it
that's essentially how you fix a lot of
memory leaks
is you just manage this new and delete
okay so we
delete stuff that's going to delete all
the data that it was previously pointing
at we can say hey
now it's no pointer so all this does is
it just zeros out the memory
that it's pointing to just makes it all
zeros
and then we're going to play around with
another idea here
we're going to declare a standard object
that is a float
and we're just calling this a thing give
it the value 500 and now we can say that
this is the pointer the stuff one equals
a reference
to thing so what will happen here is
pretty interesting as well
this uh reference here basically says
get me the pointer
to this memory give me a reference to
the memory it's essentially the same
thing as a pointer so we can assign
this pointer to whatever wherever this
object starts basically
and we can we can set its value that way
but it's not actually setting the value
it's just setting
where it's pointing to so if this thing
it goes out of scope
for example stuff will stop working as
well
so for example oh let's just let's just
run this and i'll walk through all these
see outs real quick
and then i'll show you an example of how
to like bug it out our first c out
is just the address which we see there
our second c out
is the value which we see there of zero
and then we assign it to 10
and we get 10 and then we do some
deleting we assign
the thing we see out there and we get
500 which is expected because it's
pointed thing
and then we just see out the reference
to thing which we see its address
right there ends in f8 and we also want
to look at the pointer
right after that and we see it has the
exact same address that they're starting
at the same place
and then if we do a reference to a
pointer that's essentially a pointer to
a pointer it's where the pointer starts
going to determine that it's four
bits wide now another interesting thing
real quick i'll show you if you switch
it to 64
you'll get wider pointers so 64-bit
programs typically use up a little more
memory so if you don't need it to be 64
it's often a good reason not to is
because you save a little bit of space
taking a minute to recompile what are
you doing program oh i'm in select mode
yeah that'll do it so you see that the
jump in the pointer is from zero to
eight rather than
from four to eight now it's just a way
you can kind of tell there are other
ways to
check the width but that's just
something you can see from this example
okay now let's do a little thing where
we let this go out of scope after
assigning
so we'll do something like this we get
rid of this one here because we know
it's not scope
so this starts a new scope declares this
thing it was 500
stuff now references that and then we go
out of scope so what happens
when this scope ends is this all this uh
float thing equals 500 this all gets
deleted
so this reference to it the data is not
going to be the same
it's been deallocated it's been deleted
so this is going to be a bad
reference now you got to watch out for
this sort of thing in code because the
memory
is being managed by the original one and
you see we get some strange errors we
get this weird number
it's basically whatever was left in
memory that's what it decides it was and
it is no longer
500 it is is that you could still look
at the memory addresses which might be
helpful for debugging in some cases
but in general if what you assigned to
goes out of scope and deletes you got to
make sure your pointer
stays up to date as well so one of the
things we can do to help
catch this is if we know that this
reference is no longer going to be valid
we can say stuff equals
well we don't want to do it necessarily
in this scope but i guess we could
we just want to set it to null pointer
and that way when we try to do a c
out on the value we should get an error
and it's better to get an error
than for your buggy code to keep running
because at least you know you can fix it
before you
go deliver it so here we see we get an
exception throne
and is an access reading violation we
see it's all zeros that's because we set
the memory to no pointer
and that's better than getting bad data
because our
analyzer stuff is going to catch it at
least now let's talk a little bit about
the errors that can be
thrown when you're working with this new
operator
this is a really deep subject i'm not
sure if i'm going to get it into all of
it sure i'm going to end up leaving a
lot out but i'm going to try to at least
cover all the basics that you need to
know
so one of the things that can happen is
it can throw a bad allocation
if you're out of memory and and can't
allocate memory to this variable and
it throws a bad alex so you can wrap
this in a try catch block
and see if you can catch a bad alec bad
allocation
and if you do you can give a little
message or whatever you want to do
whatever you need to do
you can also print out this
e dot what to see exactly what the
problem was
so this is pretty much never going to
fail it's always going to have memory
for flow but we can introduce a case
where it should fail just to test it out
okay so here is a case that would
eventually crash our program
due to extreme memory leaks uh that i
will show you and eventually it will
throw a bad allocation now this is very
simple
chunk of code we still got the same
floater floater pointer to
the float named stuff and in this try
block we're just gonna keep assigning it
new floats
indefinitely but eventually eventually
this will throw
a bad allocation or it should and in
that case we'll catch it and get this c
out and it'll tell us what it is now
we'll just watch what happens
when i run this this is this is a prime
example
of a memory leak now look at the memory
over here it's up to one gig already
and it's going higher and higher two
gigs three gigs it's just keep going up
nothing's going on the console
four gigs i don't know if this is gonna
mess up the recording it's possible that
it might
but we're not deleting the and freeing
the old memory
we're just leaving whatever was
previously signed in memory and just
declaring new ones so there's just a
whole bunch of
our memory is just getting filled up
with new floats of the zero value
this computer has 32 gigs of memory so
this is going to take a really long time
but once this hits you know somewhere
close to that maximum range or
just there's no more memory left to
allocate then it's going to throw this
bad allocation
uh i'm not sure if it's worth waiting
that long now we're already this far
let's keep waiting
also this incremental steady rising is
often a clear sign that you have a
memory leak longer your program runs the
more memory starts using
usually a clear sign oh we will be going
over some ways to
combat this critical problem okay
getting close to 32 gigs of memory we
should be crashing soon
it's probably just caching it onto my
hard drive uh probably is just cashing
it onto my hard drive all right well
before this actually glitches out my
computer i'm just gonna stop it
but you're just gonna have to trust that
eventually it would error and throw this
bad allocation
and this e dot what would just be
standard bad alec
is what it would say would say this
put it in comments there yeah i just
can't let it run that long i i'm
fearing that it's going to mess up my
recording more than anything and i'll
have to redo all of this
so all right let's go over some ways to
help detect this sort of thing and
combat
these problems other than just catching
well i guess you always want to be
checking for the bad allocation in a
real
program in general but let's let's look
at some other stuff
one of the things you see a lot of
programmers do is
redefine new
or overload it so that it gets call it
calls your own function
and a lot of times you'll see people
wrap it in
an if defined debug so this only builds
with
your debug and there's the end if so if
i switch this to release
it just uses the standard new
if i switch it to debug it will now
define all this code
and we'll see some data about what's
happening with our new
let's go ahead and hit this
and we see we had a new call at main.cbp
line 18.
if we take a look at our code line 18
here yes so i've simplified the main
to now just call function so it goes
into a new scope
and there's line 18. so we could also
define this for
delete and we've implemented
a logger for the delete now delete's a
little different you can't do it exactly
the same as new of course
so i just had to call this function
before it does the actual delete
and that way we can log a line in a file
so this is how loggers and memory
management
tools are started they usually just like
save everything to a class make sure it
gets deleted all that
and this is a very simplistic way of
just visually getting a look from your
console
but you can imagine how this could be
expanded to be like a full
memory manager if you just kept going of
course we haven't even messed with the
array versions but of course
you would have to overload all those as
well okay
well i know this has been a lot about
pointers and
how to manage them with new and delete
so where do we go from here i think
we've covered enough in this episode
stay tuned for next episode where we
will be talking about shared pointers
and unique pointers
[Music]
consider becoming a patron yourself if
you like this kind of stuff and would
like to support it for
further or just like the video or share
it or whatever it may be
stay tuned for more coding and tutorial
stuff
map code tech tutorials over and out
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you